let's say that she found out from the
doctor that you your sperm was dead but
she didn't want your feelings to hurt so
she went and got inseminated got ti so
she faked the scene when I in her mouth
and she goes you like this yeah because
and then she took the out of her mouth
and went like put it inside she faked
that whole scene um what is that what
[Music]
happened what is something welcome back
to careful boys we're careful boys and
we're so
check it out what's something you your
partner would have to do to make you
leave her
instantaneously in the oh dude [__]
not not wash her [__] coffee cups
dude jeez what yeah
dude so that's never happened by the way
oh no it happens all the time dude they
love that why do they do that dude she
has so okay can I tell okay this is this
is just a funny anecdote okay go go go
go we in our house we have so many
[__] coffee cups it's just us two
that live there right and when I went to
your house to to stay for when we when
we shot at Trump Tower right and you're
like go grab a cup I look at your
cupboard and it was like four cups dude
it was like literally four cups nice
that you guys had I go home I tell my
wife I'm like you know how many cups
Bart has he has a family of three I was
like they have like five cups and then
I'm like we have way too many coffee
cups how many do you have coffee cups
just coffee cups like these types like
maybe she's a she's a connoisseur like
she's a collector for sure but not
there's too many still I'm going to make
you guys oh more than 20 more than 20
wow maybe 15 bro I have like [__] 40
of them dude really that's [__] [__]
dude is that is that collector [__]
though also can dude no this [__] you
have a big kitchen though you have a big
kitchen we our kitchen how many coffee
cups you need that are that are
cat-shaped we have all oh that makes
sense though you know how they are yeah
it's like emotional trauma or something
but it's just like you got to you got to
wash your coffee cups dude you got to
wash they don't wash them we have to do
it what they do is they'll take one for
each day and at the 17th day they wash
it oh dude yeah they will is that she
does always a fresh one thankfully I
have gigantic hands I can get like
[__] 35 coffee cups like just doing
this [__] like janitor's keys with my
fingers and just walking them around CL
just clanging around just clanging
around but yeah so yeah that that for me
so we spent 3 minutes talking about how
you're going to leave your girl for not
washing her coffee cup it's it's it's a
slow she already does but it's like you
do it enough like it compounds over time
or the anger go it's like eroding a
waterfall what was her response to you
when you told her like hey clean your
cups she's like I will my bad I'm
tripping and I go all right but she does
it again o yeah but you know it's well
that's cool it's not that big of a deal
so that's I just want to be acknowledged
sometimes it's all yeah I get it that's
cute that's nice so so leave instantly
is the topic oh leave instantly oh sh my
bad dude I misheard you sorry Bart you
want to go leave instantly well I was
thinking cuz I have I think I have a
pretty high
bar it's like let's see cuz I'm like if
like let's say she was like okay I ha to
break this to you but my name's actually
Sarah Silverman and I'm a CIA agent oh
cool sexy what you
yeah you're making this like a fantasy
right now sex is that a fantasy you're
getting bed up oh [__] like has to be
something else you been lying to me this
whole time you're that like has to be
like an IRS agent I got to tell I got to
tell you something my name is Sam
Silverman I'm a [__] guy yeah
sexchange operation and ta is not yours
what if Gio was a dude you know what's
crazy Gio dude I did tell her I was like
I was like this is crazy because it's
beyond my brain cells but I was like I
think I love love you so much just as a
person that if you became a dude I would
still stay with you give me one
second is that gay or what why but like
why did why do you even have that
thought I mean girls do cuz they ask you
if they stay if you would stay with them
if they were worm I always have crazy
thoughts wor wait what and you said yes
is that a you okay real real I kind of
understand I have crazy thoughts all the
time I kind of understand that that's
like very Roman but what if she had a
dick though what if she had a big old
[__] D so I would have to like you
know I'm not turned on by a penis you
suck it off she's trying to Peg you
every night too I would have to work my
way around and find a new Dynamic you
got to build it up but my intent is to
make it work she loves hand jobs likeing
them she loves handies and hand jobs are
easy super easy every day do you ever
seen this for easy that sounds like Bart
super cook she's trying to catch up you
know what I mean Bar's a super cook
probably huh hand jobs are you could do
your to get
I think you don't understand the prompt
though like what's going to make you
leave that's what I'm saying so I've
been that's why I've been brainstorming
in my mind cuz I cuz the bar is really
high she's like ta is not yours hey
that's a high bar though that's a high
bar that's a very high bar You' been
raising that one t your for sure million
you're out damn I do love that
are wait wait wait are you out no matter
who the real dad is though it's really
good are you out no matter who is
or get what if was a real dad because
all of the [__] kids look like David
when they come out yeah they do every
[__] Enzo look like David ta look
like David maybe David looks like the
kids David David looks like the kids
maybe David has a problem yeah maybe
it's him bro damn that's a tough maybe
Dave is Johnny apple seed and all the
chicks in our group Johnny apple seed
because you know what it's tough man you
know before you have a kid it's easy to
man [__] that whatever right but then in
you build a crazy Bond right and then
you're you're his dad he's your son but
then also my other side of me is like
but it was never meant to be begin to
begin with I've just been living a false
life for 6 years so do I correct that
life or do I go based off of what we
have like do you demolish the house or
do you just keep remodeling your here
here's a situation that might you might
stay let's say that she found out from
the doctor that you your sperm was dead
but she didn't want your feelings to
hurt so she went and got inseminated by
D she didn't [__] somebody she just got
a sperm donor by David jerk off in a cup
so she faked the scene when I [__] in
her mouth she goes you like this yeah
because and then she took the [__] out of
her mouth and went like put it inside
she faked that whole scene um what is
that what happened no is that what
happened um you get pregnant like that
we were getting
creative we workshopped that
one that might save it though that might
save it that saves it huh wow Bart's
weird you know what rhymes with save it
David David David that would repair the
situation how about
that I can we do a blood test with you
guys and David just for fun you are not
the father as a JK Adventure Adventures
can we call Mor just for fun I'm also
weird too obviously because let's say it
really was David right okay okay okay
here we go here we go this is going to
be weird if it really was
David he loves I love David so much mhm
I love Gio so much I love Tao so much I
would be like we need to figure
something out what the hell is going on
what happened between you two how a
family group yeah how did that happen
how do we move forward cuz I love
everybody here and what if there like
reverse cow girl happen oh yeah what if
she's like same with you I went you like
that hey guys this isn't funny anymore
that's disgusting how did it lead up to
reverse cowgirl what happened disgusting
yeah what happened to the how did that
that's what happened that's a rainy
night that's how much they disrespect
you how did it happen reverse cowgirl
hat
and I loved it with eye contact somehow
Steve Green wrote that one so you'd be
willing to work out something well I
also know I'm not easy to be with so I'm
like what makes you want to stick around
cuz you went through torture
by yeah cuz I'm like I'm like hugging a
C I'm a cactus if and you're hugging it
every day like what makes you want to
hug this Cactus you could leave any time
maybe she's Me Maybe she's a
porcupine it's all she knows but your
scenario maybe she's a porcupine that
seems like it could pass because it's
more like the out of the intention of
like she really wanted to save my
feelings and then maybe she like she
knew what my dream was she just wants my
dream to come to life you know yeah this
is why she thinks we're the dumbest men
on Earth by the way we created a sick
scenario no that'd be a tight movie
We're not the dumbest all right someone
else's turn D okay I'll go I'll go if
Tiff came up to me and was like I'm in
love with somebody else I think I would
be like all right then for real i' be
like all right then and it was David
that's it D David again it's David cuz
it's like it's [__] David if if if
that person if if she came up to me at
that point and she really felt that like
okay I need to tell this [__]
that like I'm going to love with someone
else I don't want to be with you anymore
sit no she's not leaving you cut the
losses I'm like I'm out what if it's
this though what if it's not even I fell
in love what if um she was like hey
there's this guy I met at work or
whatever when I I don't know I feel like
some like crazy connection I don't just
not not romantic or anything just like
she just feels a certain way like in the
beginning of it oh that's interesting
and she like let me know transparent or
it could even be like y I think she's
like like I don't know I feel like like
my brother or like like we get each
other she just feels guilty already so
she wants you to so already inside I'm
like
this I'm fired up I'm pissed that was a
good fight but because you were raised
by so many women yeah yeah so then I'll
will I'll act out and be really Petty
and I'll be passive aggressive all day
and I just she'll be like are you upset
I'm like I'm not even worried about it
I'm even worried about it and then 3
days later I'll do something that'll
like really make her mad I'll you know
smash a coffee cup oh I broke a coffee
cup and another one and another one and
another one they just keep slipping on
my [__] hands yeah
cut uh I think if you hit me with that I
think that would be a separate
conversation I think we'd have to be
like well what the [__] are you telling
me about this for I think I'd get fired
up I think I'd be pretty mad but I don't
know I think her someone is already she
doesn't even need to commit anything do
anything it's just her heart is
somewhere else you wouldn't want to like
what about like coup's therapy let's try
to make it work fix I think I would
exhaust those things for sure oh I see
what if she was like what if one of her
friends at work talked her into making
an only
fans that's so funny cuz and it's a
chick friend too right yeah and she's
just like I want to do it it's
liberating what kind of content is it
[__] you know what kind of know
cucumber nudes in Solo play cucum like
if I get to fil man cucumbers and
bananas I don't think that will bother
me now all your jiujitsu homies
subscribe to her oh that would be weird
bro that' be really weird she's doing it
in GES and cucumbers and bananas
cucumbers and bananas but you'd have to
decide at that at the moment she's
telling you if you're leaving or staying
you don't know how it's going to happen
she's just saying I'm going to do it I
think ini you in or not I think I'm in
dude you're in I think I might be in
let's go Nick likes money no well it's
just like no she don't want to make
money she wants to make
free oh it's charity it's not about the
money I I just want to express myself be
a Voyer you know yeah it's not about the
money money I don't think that'd be I
say that now but I'll probably be a
[__] he said a small tiny man dude
I'll be a small tiny man about it raised
by
women Nick's going to be the boyfriend
at the strip club I don't know I think
would have to take a lot it would have
to take a lot for her to for us to get
divorced in your bar is pretty high
that's crazy but you've been I think the
longer you've been together the bars
higher and higher well it's like it's
like you know we could work through [__]
you know what I mean like like I I think
initially like a couple years ago I may
not say that but now I know that like we
could work through hard conversations
and and try to figure some [__] out cuz
it's not perfect obviously like you want
to throw away like it's based on how I
handle it like my ability to keep it
cool and and stay C what if she's like I
lied about my age I'm actually still 19
I'll be like [__] say
less I'll be like sh so she went to high
school early yeah she was a smart guy so
so you're technically a pedophile yeah
and I'm like not anymore but she robbed
his cradle she's like but I won't tell
anyone for
now and dangles it over my
head you're zany what if she's like I
lied I'm actually
[Music]
48 I don't think i' be I don't think
I'll be that makes a lot of sense she
can't have kids anymore like age is like
the easiest I'm like who
cares all right cool we don't have kids
we have kids actually bet traal is
different than age I think betrayal is
the biggest okay what if she's like what
if she goes I want to get rid of these
dogs I'm tired of them I told her I was
like bro if you if you divorce me yo I'm
taking the [__] dog what if she's
like I want to stay with you these dogs
got to go divorce
her and they go by murder oh dude oh God
you got to do it too that's a weird
change of heart and I'll look at her
differently you got to kill the kids and
I think I might be like I'm taking the
dogs dude I might I don't
know how about a real like a a this
video is just trying to break Nick a
Down to Earth one it's Jiu-Jitsu or me
oh jiujitsu he picks her come on D he
picks her he's I'll do
[__] yeah I'll I'll pick her then
really that's so easy easy really but
then I'll go crazy cuz if I don't like
exert that you got to do something I'll
[__] I'll probably beat her up she'll
reward you I'll beat her [__] ass
I'll commit domestic violence probably I
I'm done trying to break
you somebody else go dude Jo's turn we
wanted to be really excited Anthony real
quick I'll go cuz I have a uber about to
show up cuz I got to go to the airport
uh she'd have to just she'd have to just
cheat on me and it'd be over it'd be
completely over if she Che cheats on you
we're Riders I'm a rider I'm I ride and
ride and ride if you betray me it's over
it's over yeah if you ride with somebody
else it's over it's that simple does it
need to be physical or is it emotional
or uh physical is like seals the deal
yeah that's a big one so it's not
physical but she's like in love with
David yeah no it's over she's in love
with David what am I going to do I'm not
going to get in her way either I love
her I love her to death I love her too
much yeah what if she turned all your
woo to cardano I kill her I kill her and
I kill my I kill her oh wow then i k
Charles
hoskinson's the founder of cardano the
founder of cardano and I finally just
you know and then I like take a shower
with his blood yeah and then yeah and
then I move on with my life I have a
great life nothing's going to split me
and Hannah only if she tells me she's
the queen of Wales and I'm like [__]
that [__] I don't want the attention
what if she [__] presses the button
that blows up Japan oh [__] that I'm
American Amer damn that's good so
anything could H like let's say she
killed
NOP oh killing someone the makes her
hotter to me yeah what what if you found
out she was a a guy no no a a a kid a
kid offender oh that kind yeah oh no so
she so she goes around she goes around
defending kids she's saying shut up
she's saying all kinds of she say you
can't play you probably pooped your
pants right now huh that's why you can't
get down from that slide she'll take
balls from kids kick it is that over
your line that's that's over the line
for a lot oh no smash kids iPads if I
find out news like that she's like Mr
Beast isn't real it's a it's going to be
a homicide suicide hell oh you love her
L her cuz I had to kill her so she
doesn't hurt kids but I have to kill
myself cuz then I hurt my love
yeah that's so Japanese view that is
very Japanese that's how I found out Gio
really loves me cuz she likes kid no no
her no cuz her the to her the scum
people of the Earth are the kid hurters
right and then so I was like you know
cuz I always have crazy thoughts I was
like Hey like what would you how would
you feel if you found out I was one yeah
and then I thought she was just going to
leave me right away or do whatever she
was like well the first thing I would do
is isolate taica away from you but then
you're like what if ta's not that hot
and then and then she'll keep him safe
and then I would figure out um I would
figure out like how long ago this
started how long have you been dealing
with this and then also still even allow
me taica time but she's involved oh yeah
and I was like wow like you would really
want to make this work that's crazy damn
whoever was the ad break on this
show you're [__] welcome I think it's
War
Parker is this the last episode yeah
this is it guys okay uh mine are pretty
simple it's just we both have this thing
with like if she just wanted something
else I would leave and if I wanted
something else she would leave we're
very just if she just even wanted yeah
cuz I think that's like a thing where
like I don't want to force her to figure
out a way to want me and I don't want
are you guys uh open to open
relationships cuz that something else is
that considered wanting something else
no we're I think we just never really we
don't have a yearning for anything more
than like what we've got and I think
it's like a thing where if she felt like
I wasn't enough and she wanted something
else or something different then I'm
like not supposed to stand in the way of
that and she's not supposed to stand in
the way of whatever if that happens to
me that's nice that's really very simple
anything else I think we at least will
give it a shot yeah and if we fail then
what's the worst that could happen it
already [__] [__] hit the fan anyway
so yeah yeah wow that's sweet what about
you
and I 20 minutes come on
guys
[Music]